Oh what a lovely day!
I'm so excited! I want to train, jump and play
Oh damn stuff got serious
Look at the flowers, target.
Woah woah woah!
Don't look at the jerk, it's alright
OUCH!
Gotta do my job no matter what
Blgrhhhh
Oh no, my new pants got dirty
Bull-eyes
You spin me right round baby right round!
bang
Damn I'm good at this
I don't want to play soccer I wanna shoot
[ROBOTIC FEEDBACK]
[Robot Noises]
HELL YEAH I'M THE BEST!
GIMME THAT
OH LET'S GET DONKEY KONG
... Still got it
alright gimme some style points at least
Are you serious dude
I'm dead tired of these fellas
This boy crazy
HEY YOU'RE BLOCKING MY VIEW
Thank you
What's this, Chuck Norris?
Not cool bro!
Should I?
YO YO YO YO YO CHILL
IF I SHOOT YOU, THE VIDEO WILL BE DEMONETIZED, STOP IT NOW
Oh my god I cannot shoot those eyes uwu
BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM
SCREW THIS I JUST WANTED TO PLAY OUTSIDE FOR ONCE
triumph!
Going commando
Mannequin challenge again?
IT'S NOT 2016
YOU DON'T BOTHER ME ANYMORE
OH NO NOT THE BEES I HATE BEES
ALRGH MY SENSORS!!!
SCREW YOU IN PARTICULAR
Grabbing this gun makes the bees dissapear
No more bees, it's time for:
you're ugly
but you're uglier
no, I think you're uglier
Damn you both are ugly
but you're the ugliest
Aw shit here we go again
pff
Don't you start
Stop it A-hole
I'm so excited, never had a birthday before!
Is that for me?
YOU GOT ME A DOGGY YAAAY
I'mma call him Jeremy
wait wut
Are you serious
You've got to be kidding me
I'm out.
I'm respecting your beliefs by grabbing the gun, but asserting my authority as a killer robot by going away anyway.
NO
JEREMY I'M SORRY THEY'RE MAKING ME DO THIS
YOU'RE ALL PSYCHOS
JEREMY CALM DOWN EVERYTHING'S GONNA BE FINE
I've had enough of you
Screw your stick
Dance monkey, dance
THIS IS FUN, ISN'T IT?
COME ON, JEREMY
COWABUNGA!
Hasta la vista, losers